welcome everyone to
the yale conference on japanese soft
power in east asia
my name is dan mattingly i'm assistant
professor in the department of political
science
here at yale also a member of the
council on east asian studies
and i'm delighted to welcome everyone to
this event
we'd like to thank especially the
consulate
general of uh
japan um and
uh uh in boston for generous funding
and especially tsu omori the consul
general
of the consul general in japan in boston
uh so this is a workshop on soft power
competition
and especially japanese soft power in
east asia soft power
competition in east asia i think is of
growing importance as japan
a long time south tower superpower
in the region now faces china which has
considerable ambitions to overtake japan
in the united states
as a significant soft power player
especially in east asia so in this
workshop of two papers
uh we're going to start with of the
logic of soft power competition evidence
in east asia we'll have a brief uh break
from e25 to 840
expert intermission and then we'll uh
have the paper does public diplomacy
sway foreign opinion
identifying the effect of high-level
visits
so we have a really fantastic amazing
crew of
panelists who are part of this
and so i'd like people to go around and
briefly uh introduce themselves in
alphabetical order
by uh by last name so i'd like to start
with
uh if you could just briefly identify
who you are and the institution you're
from
uh starting with amy catalinic from nyu
hi everyone amy catalina from nyu long
story about how
i uh my career is the product of soft
power
efforts by japan and new zealand omitted
but uh happy to share that
at this time great thanks
uh next uh charles i'm uh charles
crabtree assistant professor of
government at dartmouth college
uh really happy to be here
graham if you wouldn't mind hi i'm
graham davis professor of international
security at the university of york in
the uk
thank you hey christina
christina davis professor of government
and director of the program on u.s japan
relations
at harvard university okay and if our
panelists can see the list now that's in
the chat you can also just jump in
um so uh benjamin goldsmith is next
um yeah good morning uh from australia
i'm ben goldsmith a professor of
political science
in the school of politics and
international relations at the
australian national university uh
and also head of school thanks very much
for inviting inviting me
and our paper
hi i am naima green riley i am a phd
candidate at harvard university
and really excited about this entire
program because i was once
in a former career a public diplomacy
officer at the state department
so i'm you saku horiochie professor of
government
and mitsui professor of japanese studies
at dartmouth
and also i'm also very happy to attend
this
conference and presenting our new paper
hi i'm trevor incerti i'm a phd
candidate at yale university
i'm currently a visiting research fellow
at the university of tokyo institute of
social science
and an associate researcher at the
wasada university institute of political
economy
hi i'm thompsou or chang if that's more
convenient for you to pronounce
and i'm a third year phd student in
political science here at yale
i study security and military studies
broadly defined
i don't have a list in my hands but my
last name starts from
k so probably me taehyung
kim from seongyungwan university south
korea seoul
i'm a professor of political science and
dean
graduate school for a national strategy
good to meet you
everybody and look forward to good
papers and discussions
uh good morning everyone i'm tetsuro
kobayashi from
department of media and communication at
the city university of hong kong
i study political communication
political psychology and public opinion
in east asian countries
good to see you hi i'm another kobayashi
yoshi kobayashi and i am an associate
professor
at university of leeds in the uk
hi everyone my name is tom lee i'm an
assistant professor of politics at
pomona college out in california happy
to be here
hi everyone i'm adam liff associate
professor of east asian international
relations at the hamilton lubber school
at indiana university where i also run
the 21st century japan politics and
society initiative glad to be here
good morning i'm sudan i'm an associate
professor at the division of
international studies at korea
university
we will be joined later by jennifer lind
professor of government at dartmouth
college
and i'm philip lipscy i'm associate
professor at
university of toronto where i also
direct the center for the study of
global japan
great to see you all
[Music]
i'm kelly matoush i'm an assistant
professor of political science at
florida state university
i forgot to introduce myself again i'm
daniel mattingly i'm an assistant
professor
of political science at yale university
hi everyone i'm colin morshed i'm a
second year student
in the political science department at
yale
and i'm so glad to see all of you here
after having corresponded with most of
you
um so glad you're all here
good morning everybody i'm kenneth
mcelwain i'm professor at the institute
of social science
at the university of tokyo great to see
everybody
so we have uh professor nai also as well
sorry my list is my participants list is
not alphabetical
i'm joe nai uh former dean at the
kennedy school
and now a research professor at the
kennedy school of government at harvard
hello i'm maria abnikova i'm an
assistant professor of global
communication at georgia state
university and currently a wilson fellow
i'm writing two books on chinese soft
power really excited to be here thank
you
hi i'm daniel smith i'm associate
professor of government at harvard
university thank you for having me uh
participate in this event
morning uh my name is atsushitago i'm an
associate dean
of the graduate school of political
science waseda university in tokyo
we have seiki tanaka who will
be possibly joining us later this
evening
hi i'm mike thies i'm at ucla in
political science department
and chair of global studies
hi i'm mike toms i'm a professor of
political science at stanford
i'm also the chair of the political
science department and
a senior fellow at the stanford
institute for economic policy research
looking forward to having this
conversation with you today
hi i'm hikari yamagishi i'm a phd
candidate at yale
thank you thanks everyone so
first up we have a paper on which
i'm a co-author of a really great
team uh including a fantastic group of
phd students from yale uh chong
chu colin morris had takara yamaguchi uh
and trevor and certi as well
as francis rosenbluth and i hear
also of uh yale and seki tanaka at the
university of groningen
and so presenting our paper will be uh
chong wu chu
colin morse heads and hikaru yamagishi
so
uh without further ado uh please
take it away all right so today we're
presenting the
paper on the logic of soft power
competition
with survey evidence from asia we'd like
to give our great thanks to the
consulate general of japan and boston
for generous funding for
research providing us an opportunity to
study questions of great theoretical and
practical importance and of our personal
and professional interests thank you
very much the historical backdrop of our
inquiry in
are two east asian countries vying for
regional dominance
japan's preeminence as the region's
exporter has waned a little since its
post-world war ii heyday
but observers note that japan is
building its coffers of another product
it's gross national coalition call it
in his long reign in office former
former prime minister abe
led a cool japan program a
multi-ministry effort coordinated by the
cabinet office
with specific goals like increasing
trade and tourism
product purchases attracting foreign
public opinion for foreign policy and so
on
and we picked this picture as perhaps an
emblematic moment at the 2016 rio summer
olympics
closing ceremony the handover ceremony
where there was a video montage with
japanese athletes hello kitty
classic manga characters and prime
minister abe stuck in tokyo traffic in
the beginning saying he won't make it to
rio on time
but with the help of um super mario the
video game
and his friends he teleports through a
pipe and pops up in the middle of the
stadium
at rio as mario a viral moment but for
us
a point the point being that you know
the softer side of
even the softer side of saw power
animation cuisine
it's not just bottom up and political
leaders are actively harnessing these
resources for promotion and policy
for national gains
and chinese leaders have thrown their
hats in the ring as well
here are some quotes from former
president who we must enhance culture as
part of soft
power and president xi the vision is
that chinese cultural soft power has
grown much stronger so this is in the
ccp
congress sessions so with the aim of
winning this public opinion war the
chinese communist party sees
increasing the country's soft power as a
core national goal
and has spent lavishly on efforts like
the belton road initiative as well
so in this new era of soft power
competition
our question is does soft power
influence
global attitudes what soft power
resources work
and under what conditions so right now
i'm spending a quick three slides on an
overview and then
i'll go a little deeper into the theory
and then colin and chang will take over
for case selection and design
and i'll i'll do some closing remarks
so we go there's a robust literature
um on soft power and political science
and building on nye we structure our
theoretical framework
with three key soft power resources
so the first is culture things like art
and drama the second one is political
values such as freedom of speech
in a responsible government bill of
rights and so forth
and finally foreign policy another
country's official international
relations policy with one's home country
so with this framework our main theory
is as old the pr insight is practically
as old as the concept of soft power
itself
but it's that domestic political context
matters so more specifically when the
bilateral relations are depoliticized
in the domestic political arena soft
power efforts can work
but when bilateral relations are
politicized
in domestic politics they can backfire
excuse me
our main result or rather sorry our
research design
so we use a survey experiment set up and
we expose the audience to soft power
promotion efforts
by china and japan in two key cases
so south korea first or the south korea
relationship
sorry south korea japan relationship and
the south korea-china relationship
are politicized in domestic politics
and malaysia where the malaysia
japan relationship and the
malaysia-china relationship
are relatively de-politicized
our key results are that soft power can
be effective
in non-politicized environments but
backfires in politics
in politicized environments so we find
that in malaysia
soft power efforts succeeded in changing
cooperative attitudes towards each of
the countries promoting soft power
but in south korea they backfired
our second point is that content matters
soft power research has showed similar
patterns of effectiveness across
contexts so for instance
foreign aid and culture were more
effective in moving respondents
willingness to cooperate favorably
whereas
treatments showing political values were
less effective and we'll discuss this
later whether it was
because of our setup or because of
oh various factors we'll talk about
later the theoretical payoffs of our
paper
we theorize and test soft power's
effects across the three these three
core soft power resources we show how
aid influence attitudes in non-recipient
countries
and we contribute to the literature on
public diplomacy
so diving in further into our theory
so there are three types of soft power
resources
the first one is culture so
these are things such as
art literature various
cuisine and so forth that increases the
attractiveness
of a country's profile to
the recipient individual this is an
image of pokemon characters
and
animation character from japan at the
macy's
thanksgiving day parade um foreign
policy theoretically
is a host of different policy
initiatives um in our exam in our study
today we focus on
international aid this is a picture of
oda being delivered from japan
and political values so this um
has been long established in the
literature
originally by nai and others as
emblematic from the us's
robust democratic liberalism
this picture is from the 1960s u.s japan
security protests in japan so that's the
diet building and that's all those
people protesting
so our theory from the individual level
so on the right here is kind of the
original environment in which
an individual is operating so this is a
low politicization country say it's
country x
and this is a treatment a dosage of
any soft power resource so let's say
this is japan
um let's say this is a documentary on
japanese
beverage making and its origins of
whiskey for instance
and when the environment is low
politicized
not as well politicized to begin with
it's more or less a blank slate
or less politicized slate so the
individual sees this
is exposed they have updates about their
beliefs about the foreign nation
and its trustworthiness and coolness
and we hypothesize that it increases
support for security and or
economic relationships so next time
they're out
for a gift for a friend they might look
for a japanese whiskey rather than
something else
on the other hand this is another
country country y
in a highly politicized environment and
again they might get exposure to a soft
power resource
but in this case the mechanism is a
little bit different because they
already have priors about the country
and what happens is it's rather than
updating information it's more of a
prime
that associates back to their already
held negative emotional reactions
which lead to less support for security
and economic relationships
so note for this
this slide is that it's not necessarily
that a priming is going to lead to less
cooperative behavior in terms of the
bilateral relationship
it's that empirically we find that
we the literature finds and we work
within a framework where more countries
when they politicize
a bilateral relationship it's more
antagonistic and in a negative sense
than a positive one
um unfortunately and so that's why when
they get primed about a politicized
relationship the result is negative it's
not necessarily about the
having the prime or not itself
all right so moving on to case selection
calling
okay um so with full understanding that
this panel is
awash with experts on uh the region
i'm going to hazard an introduction of
our soft power senders these are the two
countries really vying for
influence through soft power in east
asia and abroad
so they have fairly distinct
characteristics i think everybody here
is
probably familiar with japan has
relatively successful soft cultural
power
and its economic success is very well
known a japanese government has spent
quite a lot on developmental assistance
and foreign aid programs throughout the
post-war era
chinese cultural power has considerable
reach depending on the content type and
market and the government emphasis
on this is increasing additionally
china's growth rate over the past few
decades
has gotten it the sort of attention i
think that japan received for
the economic miracle and recently we've
seen
huge highly publicized developments like
the one belt one road initiative which
are
sort of meant to showcase chinese
assistance within a broader foreign
policy framework
so now i'll quickly run through the
dyads of our cases
so up top i should i should note that
there's not really a perfectly
politicized or depoliticized case to do
this experiment
uh we made our assessments on which
countries might work
best as cases from the background on the
theoretical dimensions and
survey data from over the years about
favorability toward japan and china
we'll see more on that data
shortly but first up the japan south
korea relationship
has been pretty fraught for a very long
time
so despite a shared status as developed
democracies we see highly politicized
bilateral relations
because of historical factors like wars
colonial legacy
and more current pressing issues like
security cooperation
and territorial disputes south korea is
not really a
recipient of japanese aid and japanese
cultural goods are often targeted in
south korean boycotts
malaysia in this case is non-politicized
with
japan since bilateral relations don't
really feature in
domestic politics of malaysia so
malaysians are consumers of japanese
products
they've also received considerable
funding and technical assistance
from japan since the 1960s
moving onto the china side we see
i think a different sort of case with
the china-south korea relationship it's
politicized for very different reasons
um
the primary clash here between these
countries is over political issues
and security issues and so we've seen
disputes over
human rights issues mischaracterizations
of the south korean government's
positions
and the chinese relationship with north
korea can
also cause issues so again south korea
is not really a recipient of chinese aid
of course uh and although south koreans
do consume
uh chinese goods and cultural products i
think that's the the extent of the the
relationship there
um malaysia once again has little or no
politicization
on relations with china so it's a
recipient of loans as part of
bri um we have seen a willingness to be
selective about which
projects the malaysian government wants
to accept as part of the one belt one
road initiative
there's also a large ethnic chinese
minority in malaysia but
the domestic racial cleavages haven't
really spilled over into the bilateral
relations with china
so moving on i think we have a two by
two here that that lays out in sort of
the simplest terms i think what our
expectations
should be based on the assessments of
these
dyad's politicization levels uh so the
japan-south korea relationship is
highly politicized which suggests that
we would have a backlash effect
uh in the china south korea dyad we see
relatively less politicization but it
still exists
and so there's perhaps an opportunity
for within case variation
among the south korea respondents versus
the the japan case
malaysia japan isn't politicized so we
should hopefully see some positive
effects from treatments
and the same goes for malaysia china
so all in all i think you can see we
expect to see soft power efforts
by both countries doing better in
malaysia than in south korea
and we might expect to see some
variation among the south korea
respondent groups
okay so this is a feeling thermometer
that we took from our respondents to
visualize and sort of justify that set
of expectations
uh so what you're seeing here on the
y-axis is number of respondents
and the x-axis is feelings uh with 10
being most positive so
what we have here is like a sort of
density plot of feelings towards the
countries
and as you can see the south korean
respondents are really quite negative
about both
japan and china whereas the malaysian
respondents are
pretty much more positive about both
countries
and now we'll take a look at the surveys
so we fielded two surveys one in south
korea and one
in malaysia each survey was completed
in the primary local language so korean
and malay respectively
our first wave went out early this month
we've just finished our second wave this
week which followed up with respondents
between five and seven days after
completion of the first wave
and our intent for that second wave is
really to interrogate whether these
treatment effects are sticky um so the
results didn't make it into the paper
because of time considerations but they
will be going into
future iterations we hope you stay tuned
uh so the surveys were
administered by dyna which is an online
market research company operating in
both
south korea and malaysia for sampling we
stratified age
and gender to best approximate the
sample to the broader populations and as
a result
the malaysian sample we got matches more
or less on both age and gender
the south korean sample matches on
gender and skews just ever so slightly
young compared with the broader
population
and so overall these screenings gave us
samples of 2740
in south korea and 2716
in malaysia so we have
three soft power treatment groups and a
control group in both countries
so the three soft power treatment groups
are meant to track the theoretical
categories of soft power so
cultural products on the culture
dimension
politics as operationalized by protest
and foreign policy here is in the form
of foreign aid
so our two soft power senders or
diffusers in east asia being japan and
china
we used video treatments rather than
conventional vignettes
and this was difficult finding
comparable video treatments between
japan and china to send sort of
comparable
messaging uh was a challenge we think
that using the real video treatments
better approximates how people in south
korea and malaysia
are going to encounter soft power so
these videos are drawn from fictional
media
and news clips from each country uh and
you know we would love to have our
respondents watch my neighbor totoro in
its entirety
uh but unfortunately time and money are
both limited so treatments are limited
to only a few minutes
and we have in total a three by two
factorial design with the control so
ending up with seven groups in total uh
respondents were randomly assigned to
the groups and watched at least
100 seconds of the corresponding video
treatment
uh so to go into a little more detail on
that i will hand it over to chong
oh thanks zika and thanks clay since our
seminar participants didn't have a
chance to see the actual
treatment videos let me briefly describe
them
for the control video we featured nature
and
flowers which we think are unrelated to
soft power in japan and china
for japanese cultural soft power we
chose that
we chose a popular japanese anime
entitled my neighbor totoro
for japanese cultures of power and we
chose a video
showing how japanese citizens
demonstrate their grievances toward
their government
especially on towards the former prime
minister of it
for the japanese foreign foreign aid
treatment we chose a video of mofa
promoting japanese contribution to
nation building projects in developing
countries
the video focuses on foreign aid for
countries other than south korea and
malaysia
so it suggests the general foreign
policy not but not the direct payment or
benefit to the target countries
uh moving on to chinese software
treatment for comparability issue um the
treatment selections for
uh chinese soft power largely echoed the
selections for the japanese soft power
with the same control video we used
another media clip from a popular
chinese
historical drama entitled the longest
stay in chiang
for chinese political assault power we
chose a video clip
showing people in hong kong protesting
against the chinese government
for the chinese foreign aid treatment we
employed a chinese uh we employed a
chinese state media's promotion video
on the belton road initiative
all the treatment videos are translated
and subtitled according to the um so
according to the software receiver's
respective languages
i.e um korean and mla
and moving on to the key outcomes
we focus on three domains of
international relations and political
economy
for economic consumption variable we
asked respondents whether they preferred
to purchase chinese or japanese
electronic products
responders were given a choice between a
chinese brand and a japanese brand for
three product lines
smartphone tv and in home appliance
each brand was randomly drawn from the
listed brand here on the screen
and responded were asked to indicate
whether they preferred one over the
other
100 point probability scale
we randomize the pair and the ordering
of brands and also the order of the
three electronic items
we later rescale the responses so so the
hundred percent represent a purchase of
this chinese
purchase of the chinese friend over the
competing japanese brand
for the two corporation questions we
asked respondents whether they think
korea
or malaysia should cooperate more with
japan or china
on trade war security matters the
responses were measured on a seven-point
liquor scale running from strongly agree
to
strongly disagree and moving on to
a kind of mechanism test in addition to
the key outcomes
that we just rendered we also measured
potential outcomes
sorry potential mechanisms first
we asked respondents how could they
think japan and china is
the responses on this statement were
measured on a five point scale
and second we provided them with an
eleven point scale
where they um to indicate their emotions
toward japan and china respectively
third we gathered three types of
generalized
trust i'll be the favorability rating of
japan and china
political trust for the japanese and
chinese government
and economic trust for japanese and
chinese products
all of which were measured on 100 point
scale
our estimation strategy is the
difference in means
and it's being reported that pandemic
replication surveys are comparable to
pre-pandemic surveys but with some
smaller effect sizes
since our surveys were conducted during
copied nineteen
the estimates of our treatment effects
may be somewhat conservative
as for the main result um the number one
takeaway
um is that software promotion
can backfire if the bilateral relations
are politicized
for this figure we combine all outcome
variables into a single dimensional
index for each soft power center and we
also conflated
all japanese or chinese treatments for
each country
we found a large backlash against the
japanese software message
in south korea while while the chinese
software message featured a positive
impact
in malaysia and then are we
um we examine the effect of each uh each
treatment on all the major outcome
outcome questions using the same um
same strategy to aggregate the questions
here we observe some hierarchical
structure of soft power sources
for example in malaysia advertising
foreign aid
significantly moves respondents
attitudes in a positive direction
and it seems cultural promoting efforts
can also pay off in malaysia
however media exposure to protests is
found to have no effect
or elicit a significant backlash for the
japanese treatment
in south korea we found a backlash
against all japanese salt power
treatments
and the chinese protein protest
treatment
we think the the protest may have caused
respondents to update their prior
beliefs about
the um the trustworthiness of the
japanese government
moving on we also investigated the
mechanisms in which our treatments
are moved to respondents perceptions
about the software centers
the most notable pattern here is that
all treatments cause strong negative
emotional reactions among south korean
respondents would these be japan and
china
in malaysia we observe strong strong
negative reactions to both japanese and
chinese protests
while the japanese cultural treatment
induced some positive impact
interestingly uh we observed the
positive impact of chinese aid
and the negative impact of of japanese
protests on malaysian respondents
perception about the two subtar the two
software standards trustworthiness
and cool japan or could cool china
we can interpret this in line with our
finding in the paper
that the um the chinese aid video works
for malaysian respondents on security
and trade cooperation
and another finding that japanese
protest video backfires
making malaysian respondents dislike
security and trade cooperation in japan
so in sum emotion seems to drive the
backlash we observe in a politicized
setting
like in south korea and generalized
trust and coolness
matter for security and trade
cooperation in a deep policies setting
like in malaysia and with that over to
you
guys
great so for future research there's two
avenues that we'd like to highlight
first one of those three soft power
resources
political values so we found
um that this we would like to unpack
this further
our hypothesis was that the protests
will show freedom
but perhaps this was our political
science minds working too readily
the inherent kind of paradox of a
protest is that
when you show someone protesting against
the government
that definitionally means that the
government is doing something that's not
matching the will of certain people
so it might be it might look like a
vision of conflict and disorder
one way to push forward is to show a
retrospective narrative of
when citizens protested and the
government changed in response
and there are also other dimensions of
political values to explore we might
have been
to western liberal democratic in our
conception of political values
there are many other dimensions like
economic performance democratic process
popular response responsiveness that can
show attractive institutional features
in different forms
uh secondly we are left with we with a
question of long run effects of soft
power
we realize that our design is a small
amount of exposure
although similar to government public
diplomacy efforts perhaps
and we can't manipulate how much country
a soft power has at the baseline
we can try to understand long-run change
in soft power however using panel
surveys and field experiments over time
and some examples being
such as an encouragement design in the
field
we could have people subscribe to
one-year subscriptions of
randomly chinese or japanese media for
instance and see how this slowly changes
their
long-term perceptions and so on
in summary in this paper we propose a
logic of soft power competition
and test it through survey experiments
we hypothesize that the efficacy of soft
power
is limited by the politicization of
relations between the sender and target
countries
we find that domestic politics does
shape self-powered effects when the
bilateral relationships are politicized
soft power efforts can backfire
and within soft power resources foreign
aid is an easy avenue to willing hearts
and minds
and so we find that content matters
and we also for next steps find that
more research on this more institutional
and more
nuanced political values dimension is
needed
thank you very much
great thank you thanks so much to this a
great team that i'm a member of
for this uh great presentation now we
have uh
a set of sort of discussion starters
uh to get the conversation rolling um
and please also feel free to
continue to use the chat function
and for attendees uh
you're also welcome to use the the q a
function as well
so first up we have a professor joe nai
from harvard
giving us comments on this paper thank
you
well i read this paper
with great interest and regarded as a
important contribution empirically
uh which has advanced how we think about
soft power by
using these video clips and survey
research you
made you provided empirical evidence
from certain things that i had
stated in general terms but never proven
um i've often said that soft power
is distinguished from other types of
power in the sense that it depends
on the eye of the beholder um and i've
sometimes used the anecdote that or a
little example that
if i want to steal your money with hard
power i pull out a gun
shoot you and take your wallet it
doesn't matter what you think
but if i want to steal your money by
convincing you i'm a guru
and that you should give it to me
it all depends on what you think
and so essentially what this paper has
done is
taken that question and said all right
how do we
see how people think and how does it
vary with the different types
of soft power resources in the different
contexts
so i think it's it's it's an important
paper
which uh advances in pure
evidence for something which previously
was
uh made without any evidence um
i i should say that uh the uh
i'll tell you this question of which
types of resources have which types of
effects are
are intriguing i'll give you a brief
anecdote
to illustrate this related to china i
was asked to give a lecture on soft
power
at the school of marxism uh at beta
at peking university in china
a half dozen years ago
and after i spoke to an audience of
1500 students and the dean that
introduced me
everything was going swimmingly except i
said something about
highway way and also about liu xiaobo
and um at the end when dean came up from
the platform again to thank me he said
it was
so great that professor nice comes open
to us
and then my interpreter stopped
interpreting and he kept talking and
then
eventually it ended up with his thanking
me again profusely
and later i asked a friend of mine who
was mandarin speaking who was in the
audience
um what was that all about he said
what he did was tell the students
that professor nye may have been the
person who coined the term soft power
but he treated it in too much in
political terms
and not enough in cultural terms
and here in china we think of it as
culture
not politics so that's an that's an
anecdotal illustration of the difference
between
the three types of resources and how it
works out politically
um i think the the interesting question
for me i mean we
we've now demonstrated that priors
matter uh empirically
but i think it would be interesting to
know what are the different sources
of domestic politicization
and if you're trying to translate this
to policy
what are the things that a country can
do
in public diplomacy given
the politicization that may or may n
occur in another country
for example how much of the
of the domestic political civilization
is because of leaders which the paper
refers to leaders
um politicizing it but sometimes it may
be in fact
uh historical and structural i mean the
korean attitudes to japan
uh persisted despite right through a
conservative korean
government and a liberal or progressive
korean government
and they're now bedeviling the efforts
that the americans are making to try to
get korea and japan to cooperate on the
issue of
of uh uh sharing intelligence relating
to north korea and so and china
um in other words it may be that the
politicization in some cases
is is historical and structural
and then the interesting question is to
what extent
if the japanese government for example
wants to exercise public diplomacy
and to use it soft power
what can it do and i didn't i didn't get
an answer to that from the paper i did
get an answer
of how it varied by the different uh
resources
but i didn't i it'd be nice to have
another twist of the
of the screw on this one step further to
know all right what could that mean
for actual practitioners of public
diplomacy
there are also it would be interesting
to know something about
time series i i mean this is uh churlish
to complain that uh
you don't have time series but um
if it would be interesting to know which
what happens when
events occur it happens over time how do
these
variables change um i noticed that the
you quoted
green riley's very good thesis
on soft power are saying that showing
that
american students who had
taken courses through confucius
institutes
or not more pro-chinese but less so i'll
be interesting to know
if one were to look i don't know whether
i know whether you have the data on this
or not
be interesting you know whether that
would have been true let's say
six or seven years ago before you had
the turn
in the attitude of americans relating to
china
uh or not but notice i think if for
future empirical studies if we could get
more on time series that would help a
lot
and there's also finally the question of
of uh
uh what policies governments make which
are
which can bring on the the uh the
backlash that you described i'm struck
having recently
been involved in discussions with
indians in
the aftermath of the recent meeting of
this quad
that occurred a couple of weeks ago
indians said that
it was intriguing that
when china started exercising its wolf
warrior diplomacy
which was obviously based on domestic
opinion
in china it was for domestic consumption
that had a terrible effect
in india uh not only the killing of
indian
troops on the border but the aftermath
of that in which you had chinese
nationalism
stimulating indian nationalist response
responses
uh which led incidentally to the banning
of tick tock in india
uh so it it'd be interesting to know
are there certain steps that governments
take which can
damage or severely damage um uh
it's its uh soft power in another
country and which therefore can be
avoided
so i i i love the paper i thought it was
great to have this empirical
uh research um
but i kind of it just made me thirst for
more
more on time series more on a wider set
of countries
but anyway as a as a major contribution
to
getting empirical research upon the
effects of soft power
my congratulations to the to the authors
all seven of them
great thank you thank you so much
professor nye um could i call for
more more research on this important
topic among other things uh
next of professor marie repnikova
maria yes can you hear me great thank
you so much for the invitation i also
really enjoyed the paper i think it's
very rich
empirically but i also found a lot of
interesting theoretical insights for me
one of the big takeaways was also the
breakdown of the democratic
authoritarian binary and analyzing the
effects of self-power which i think has
been overshadowing much of the analysis
of soft power especially when it comes
to china
this idea that because china is an
autocratic country its efforts are
dismissed um
you know preemptively or at least
considered to be ineffective and i think
your paper shows that
the fact that china is an autocratic
country doesn't necessarily make it
ineffective or failed
or failure and in fact because japan is
a democratic country doesn't necessarily
make it a success so there's kind of
this interesting
complication of the democracy autocracy
binary and thinking about soft power i
think you could kind of highlight that
even more
um in your theoretical contributions and
my comments some of them also echo
professor nye's comment about
the concept of depoliticization kind of
how to think about this further
so there are several points i wanted to
make the first one
um is that the politicization to me kind
of echoing this idea of time series it
appears to be a very dynamic concept
so it challenges kind of its
operationalization how do we know for
sure when the relationship is
politicized versus the politicized
for example in 2018 the malaysian pm
publicly cancelled a major chinese
infrastructure project
creating a rupture in the relationship
but then a year later he takes a u-turn
in resuming the relationship with china
so how does this concept account for
this such dynamic shifts and what
specific forms of behavior over time
kind of amount to this idea of
politicization of ties so kind of how do
we know when they're politicized enough
or not enough i think it's kind of a
very fluid um concept in a way
and it quickly changes so maybe it's
about washing it or observing it over
time or maybe it's about adding more
kind of
alternative variables or sub variables
that would help us explain or understand
this concept
uh the second point in relation to this
concept i think this echoes this idea of
kind of this notion that politicization
comes from leaders the way you define it
is very top down that
basically the government kind of defines
or forms or shapes the opinions of the
society when it comes to these various
countries but in reality it seems that
this relationship is often quite
interactive right the society itself
often pushes the government to frame or
or implement certain policies um that
are much more politicized and we see
this of course in the us with
china i think it's also notable in the
cases you study um but also
in many other contexts it seems that the
public opinion actually shapes these
politicization efforts um from the top
and then moreover we also can see that
at times politicization of societal
attitudes
is not the same thing as in
contradiction to kind of official
policies
so i see this a lot of my research in
africa where with regards to china we
see often very
deep politicized quote sort of attitudes
from the state but very politicized
attitudes um
on societal level but the public is very
critical of china and has preconceived
views about china
based on its economic presence but also
various rumors and assumptions about the
corrupt practices
interference chinese community taking
over and so forth so in a sense there's
kind of this predetermined views that
can
coexist with official depletization so i
think those two can be kind of
contradictory so there's more i think to
think about there
of how do you think about this concept
top down versus bottom up interactive
contradictory it's a very interesting um
idea and thirdly i think depolarization
almost presumes in your idea in your
paper it's kind of neutrality it's the
lack of negative framing
but in reality politicization in the
other direction is also i think quite
significant the pro-china
narratives or pro-japan narratives in
the case of malaysia for instance
there's been so much
politicization in the case of um
pro-china attitudes
in recent years through various state
media articles just a quick search i
found so many articles that are very
positive about china
in malaysian press that to me signals
that there is the kind of the other
direction of
politicization which is one could call
propaganda persuasion
and so forth so how does that play into
this picture should we look at
politicization from the other
side as well in addition to this kind of
i think
thinking about politicization there are
other points a couple of other points i
wanted to make
the first one is about practices of
self-power so you talk a lot about kind
of the effects
but when it comes to practices um for
instance how do
are there any major distinctions in how
china and japan practice self-power you
mentioned the resources
but do they kind of enact it differently
in one part of your paper you note how
japan
practices foreign aid more through
small-scale projects as opposed to
large-scale visible or what some
scholars refer to as prestige projects
that are implemented by china another
notable difference might be that more
there's more state-directed way of solve
power implementation in china versus
more kind of bottom-up implementation
from japan
and now there might be in the emphasis
of the key offerings of self-power which
i guess is hard to capture in this paper
but in my research i find that china's
approach to self-power is distinctively
pragmatic for instance much less so
ideational
and precisely because of its pragmatic
approach that prioritizes access and
material benefits
it appears to be relatively well
received in parts of global south
so what is what are the distinctions
between i think japan in this case and
china when it comes to their practices
their offerings not only when it comes
to effects i think that would be very
interesting
to at least mention somewhere um in the
paper and i think finally while it's
impossible to i guess undress any
or all possible alternative factors or
forces that could shape the attitudes
towards self-power
in this context it's important to at
least consider two complementary i think
explanations one is economic
um both south korea and malaysia have
very strong relations trade relations
with china but
less so with japan so there's an
economic kind of dimension there but
also
malaysia clearly has a much stronger
dependency on china with the bri so how
does this economic factor feature into
politicization or the attitudes
vis-a-vis um would
be china and japan and another
complementary factor is cultural
proximity you mentioned the diasporic
kind of factor briefly
but according to some estimates there's
almost 23 percent of chinese um
ethnic chinese um living in malaysia so
how does this shape the potential views
on china and responses to self-power
especially because one of china's
soft power and what some also describe
as sharp power strategies
is to target chinese communities
overseas so at the very least some of
these people might be also answering
your questions in the survey because
it's a very high percentage
so i think that would be very
interesting and the last points that
just came up to me after listening to
the presentation is this
idea of clarifying or complicating the
notion of political values i would
strongly
suggest that because the notion of
protest and especially anti-hong kong or
sorry hong kong
anti-government protest is very i mean
it's an automatically negative depiction
of china
but of course if you think about china's
political values at least from my
analysis of the training materials when
the train elites is mostly about
meritocracy
state capacity and accountability so
that that's what they advertise
so be and you know adding something from
their perspective would be useful to
again to westernize
this idea of self-power thank you so
much
great thanks so much uh professor
repnicova uh next we have professor
atucci
let me share the screen um
for the non-date not non-native english
speaker
being a third discussion for you know
afterwards of the excellent scholars the
toughest job and let me let me
screen share what i have think about the
paper
so highly commendable points of the
paper and the project
i assume that it's not the only outcome
of this large property project
so attention and new evidence on the
backfire is quite interesting
and i think it's very good way to direct
the research
an experiment in malaysia i think it's a
relatively new and also commendable
point
and more specifically i would like to
hear
because i know you have you guys have
done the second wave
the long-term effect oh well from
professor
uh joseph knight's comment it have to be
probably over a year over months but the
still
the ex as an experiment scholar who have
been working on the public diplomacy
a week year a week old panel is also
kind of commendable so one of the
hardest challenges for scientific public
diplomacy
or the software scholars how long the
effect of the information
continue is one of the key um
probability challenge and you guys are
doing that and i
commend that by the way that the already
nicely cited my
work so i shouldn't be greedy on that
but the
actually i have the another project that
i used
video uh and by the way it's a co
courses work by the uh digital
comparison of the university of city
hong kong city university of hong kong
uh it's 38 seconds above the 38th parlor
so it's there
um about the korean japan and the it's
the u.s military made made
um i guess it can be somehow related to
what you're doing but the
the given that i know how tough to do
the video
uh type of the experiment and that may
be
one of the critical points that i
release so i
i enjoyed reading the paper but i have
some couples questions and suggestions
and i saw that the first that the three
peers i know
many of the disc i mean the panelists
already
lays their their concerns or their
questions regarding that point but
so i make my statement very briefly but
the
i think your manuscripts can be much
stronger to defend
why those threes are key and why we
really have to focus on those
and second um my two countries all
obviously
many people would come up with this
question but the i think you need to
um mention uh for instance the status of
or lola of the media in each country
because the public pharmacy software
i mean media definitely uh plays the
significant role there and i'm curious
how does it evaluate the load of meteor
uh in public diplomacy or software in
general and in your study
and i saw that you didn't mention
anything on that so
somehow i'm very curious and most
importantly user video there's a pro and
calm and for the negative people
i faced with my papers uh left lease
they were literally nice still but they
raised the question like what were they
really watching and what information
has been um given or has been received
or more precisely manipulated
and i i think that one is
probably toughest question to you too
uh five i think i i wonder
um was it like a not competing
setting of the public diplomacy
information history issues
or peaceful country images of china and
japan
i would i i might do that so if you have
the continuation of the
project you can probably try that in the
future or
at least you have to probably defend in
a footnote or something that you know
why those threes are
you know by design
or empirical reasons i don't know what
would be the rationale but the
you probably um defend yourself there
and but uh what was the sixth point uh i
think pre-created
long-term effect is they're quite
different from korea and malaysia
i assume that more exposure to the
japanese manga
in dollar okay so for their negative or
now results for the south korea on the
total
because because they already watched
them you know repeatedly or too much
so i i i don't know um
i guess the pretty long term effect how
do you evaluate how do you think about
that and
that would be the question and finally
um i really enjoyed the project but the
i kind of feel kind of puzzling on this
point so what would be the solutions for
the backfire so
for the japanese government i think
public diplomacy is
do you know have been done in order not
to politicize
the image of japan so
by design it's very puzzling paper for
me
uh and if you you know at least
mentioned about the potential solutions
for the backfire
it will probably break uh you know and
it would be much more significant
contribution in the public diplomacy
studies
and that's it so i'll return the floor
to the
great thank you so much professor tago
for those for those comments
um so we have one more discussion with
with brief comments uh professor
kobayashi
and as professor professor kobayashi is
actually going to be a sort of
switch hitter today and because of
communication staff who has provided
comments for both papers
um but uh but brief uh brief comments on
while professor kobayashi is
talking please feel free to use the
raise hand feature uh
if you want to jump in on the discussion
um and
i will uh get to you after uh we go
first to professor kobayashi
thank you the reality is i was
completely confused and i i read the
wrong paper so i
i i'm assigned to the second paper but i
realized that i were the first people so
i'm going to
split my discussion time into into half
and half and i'm going to spend 2.5
minutes for each
so uh let me rush for for from my my
comments for the first paper
uh i learned a lot from this paper and
and thank you very much
and so interesting although i'm not a uh
expert of soft power
uh because i study public opinion east
asian countries is so much interesting
it's really
uh kind of imminent issue especially
when i'm you know living in hong kong
and you see a lot of you know hard and
soft power of
from china so uh i would like to raise
only one theoretical question
and two methodological questions one is
about so
although already you know many uh people
have pointed out
i had an uh question is foreign aid
really a part of uh
soft power so uh in the case of uh
china's foreign aid for instance there
are always suspicious
uh suspicions of so-called debt trump
and there's also an alleged motive
behind it to secure supporting voices in
the united nations for instance
and uh so the more recent cases that for
instance the the vaccine diplomacy
so-called vaccine
diplomacy is it is part of foreign aid
but for instance
paraguay was asked by china to cut off
diplomatic relations
with taiwan in exchange for providing
the vaccine so obviously there are some
kind of overlap between this kind of
seemingly soft power
uh uh and develo environment strategies
and
uh the hard part which which basically
cores uh uh some specific type of
actions
of the recipient of this aid so that's
my
uh theoretical question the the two uh
methodological questions concerns
experimental stimuli um so the design of
experiments
is very much interesting but if i take a
closer look
into the the treatments for instance in
the
uh japanese foreign aid treatment it
includes uh support for the pasco
uh in in south korea which is actually a
very sensitive issue in south korea
uh with regard to the uh the japanese
financial aid and its recipient in south
korea after 1965
treaty uh it is not difficult to imagine
that some
south korean participants are offended
by this reference to pasco for instance
the chinese foreign aid treatment also
includes support for malaysian uh sea
freight so this kind of bilateral uh
uh foreign aid is actually uh included
in this
stimuli and that would have some kind of
specific effects depending on the
context of these
bilateral relations uh the the last
point is about uh uh the hong kong
protest
uh uh uh so i i actually didn't
understand why hong kong produced
signifies the political value of china
um the uh because the recent protests in
hong kong are labelled as a
pro-independence movement by the chinese
central government so the government
initially censored the project's related
information in the mainland and
afterwards it severely attacked the
movement so
so therefore the hong kong protests have
never been something that china would
like to sell to the world uh moreover
harsh
uh clampdown of the protests invoked a
lot of international criticism
so i think uh the political value that
china wants to sell is
uh stability instead of this kind of um
hey we also accept uh protests that kind
of you know we are also free society
that kind of things
so i guess uh it might be uh worthwhile
you know
elaborating more of the values that what
kind of values that each country would
like to sell
so in the case of japan it might be like
kind of article 9
or rather than just showing the
anti-government process so that would be
more general and you know
fundamental value that japan has
something to sell to the world
thank you very much i'm going to send
the
the all the comments to the authors
later
great thank you so much professor
kolasiyah really
and to professors uh togo repnicova and
i
for those really fantastic comments uh
and all of these points are very well
taken i'm however i'm gonna
as hard as it is as a moderator i'm
gonna muzzle myself
because we have uh a great group of
people with their uh
hands raised and so um with the
uh permission of the other my other
teammates who uh
who are free to jump in i want to just
kind of keep going with the questions
and maybe at the end
uh we'll have a minute or two where we
can respond a little bit but mostly at
this point
i'd love to listen so first on the list
we have
mike thomps hi everyone
um i really enjoyed reading this paper
and i'm grateful for the opportunity to
listen to the presentation
and to the discussion so far uh you've
already been asking questions about the
details of the
treatments and the data i wanted to ask
two big picture questions about the
punch line
of the paper one is theoretical and the
other
is practical so at a theoretical level
one
way i think to read this paper is to say
that the papers claiming that attempts
to promote soft power will fail
if the intended audiences are hostile to
the message
or if you want to flip that around
another way of saying is that countries
are more likely to be successful at
promoting soft power
when they're preaching to the choir uh
than when they're not
so i wanted so my first question is
whether at a theoretical level
you think that that's a fair reading of
the paper and if so if you think that
that's a surprising theoretical claim
um my second question is about the
practical
implications of your research for policy
makers
so another big picture takeaway our way
to read this paper is that efforts to
promote soft power are most likely to
fail
in dyads where soft power might be most
needed
and if you think that that's a fair
reading do you think your findings might
be discouraging to policy makers who
want to use soft power as a way to
improve relations
in dyads that might not otherwise be
harmonious
great uh thank you next uh professor amy
catalinic
yeah i also really enjoyed the paper and
the presentation
um it's just fascinating so my comment
is sort of jumping off something that
mike
said so one of your conclusions i think
is that soft power
it just doesn't work in politicized
environments when the relationship
between
the sender and the target is politicized
so that suggests that
if if that's the case governments
shouldn't be directing soft power
resources
to those countries and i wonder if a
really nice complement to your
experiment
might be to look at the composition of
government's
soft power resources do we see a bias in
in directing those resources toward
countries where they're going to work
and your theory would lead us to expect
that governments if they're smart
should not be spending too much money in
politicized environments and i just
wonder if that's the case and
i also just to echo what mike said it is
interesting to think about the fact that
that is sort of
where soft power should be most directed
so it sort of might help us advance the
concept of soft power to understand
you know when and why it's used and and
i'm in general just a
fan of observational work especially
when it complements experiments
but thank you for the opportunity to
read the paper and see the presentation
great thanks so much next we have uh
jennifer linden benjamin goldsmith
hi everyone lovely to see everybody i
hope you're all well
um i just had a couple comments on this
this really
interesting paper um so i don't work in
the soft power
realm so much so i would love to see you
kind of frame it by
by first establishing um you know
soft power matters here's why here's the
empirical support
right so so point us to the studies that
show that this
this actually has this effect um
also uh to say well soft power comes
from
many sources but um but one way that we
know that countries can
get soft power is through their policies
so so you know and here's here's why we
know this here's the empirical support
and so on
so again it's um it's establishing
that soft power is not just something
that a country
is or that relates to its generalized
foreign policy but that you can i don't
want to say
buy soft power but that you can you can
affect it
through government policies to you know
to
um to make your country seem
more favorably um so again it would be
soft pattern
matters um soft power
uh comes from both who you are and what
you do but also
through deliberate um proactive efforts
to cultivate it
and and then the question of your paper
could be okay so
under what conditions will a country be
more successful
at cultivating it and and i think that
that brings
you to your paper um
i i had so again there's so much to like
here
and um i had so many questions but but
one thing i'll just mention that i
um that that kind of stuck out
was on unsurprisingly on the issue of
historical memory um
the paper creates these these three
categories of culture
politics and foreign policy and
you talk about if if relations are bad
in the culture realm
then they'll only be aggravated by a
government's efforts to build soft power
in that realm um and so that made me
wonder about um uh you know this culture
category
um i guess i'm not sure about the
connection between
like japanese anime and sushi
and political apologies right which you
kind of put it in that
category um and so these things just
seem really different to me again the
paper says that
relations between south korea and japan
are politicized because of
culture historical grievances and
diplomatic conflicts
and a lot of that sounds like politics
to me
um in fact i think of the countries as
actually having really good
cultural relations you know k-pop and
j-pop and all the things that they
they they share and so um
again it's mostly politics uh political
apologies
and the territorial dispute over dokdo
takashima
that seemed to be the root of the
problem um
so again i was confused about putting
everything in that kind of culture
bucket um i had one one reaction in
terms of
um at the end of the day people could
say okay these are just these
single case studies you have one neutral
as you called it country
you had one politicized country and
maybe you've just taught us something
about malaysia and japan
is sorry malaysia and korea um is there
something kind of simple that you could
do
to bolster yourselves against that kind
of
charge so maybe i'm obviously not
running this whole
thing again in these other countries but
um like mechanical turk uh in
you know some smaller study where you
could just kind of kick the tires of it
in you know um in other countries
that um you know singapore and
you know philippines australia
um you know european countries or
something like that
um if there would be something kind of
simple that you could do in like
three or four or four or five other
countries that people would agree yeah
they're quite neutral and if you you
found
actually quite similar findings i think
that would that would bolster the
credibility of your answer
yeah and i guess i'm next so just a
couple of comments yeah thanks
very much i also really really like the
paper and find it find it
um uh fascinating and providing a lot of
important insights
a couple of of comments uh
one reflects the comment i have in the
in the chat
that i i especially like the focus on
competition in the theoretical
discussion and and the framing
but i also think that's really um
underdeveloped in in the theory
especially i
i it's it's mentioned in the theory is
presented as a theory of soft power
competition um
i i would be pretty excited to see a
nicely developed theory
when for example when two states intend
to compete
uh you know i think you you mentioned
china and the us
as the obvious example uh you know think
of africa or south america and of course
asia as well but japan and china
are clearly competing and intend to
compete in my view
in in asia in the soft power realm
um but as the theory you know as it's
spelled out in most parts of the study
are sort of bilateral
uh in in the way they're set up
uh and the second
comment um is
about uh the the role of
of culture so i think there's
there's an issue with um the way
culture is discussed i think it needs to
be defined much
much more clearly anything from being
cool
to to different modes of entertainment
um uh can sort of fit in that in that
box and it's not clear at least to me
how
how that that very diverse set of
factors might might have an impact
um so those are my my two comments i i
have i'll send you written comments as
as well on the whole paper thanks
great thank you uh next we have philip
whoopsie and then michael t
after that yeah yeah i i really like
this paper uh thanks for the opportunity
to read it so i
i had uh two comments i have a bunch
more about i'll just focus on two
so so one of them is similar to what uh
she was saying in in his
uh discussing comments which is i felt
like
the paper might need some kind of theory
about
how existing public diplomacy efforts
relate
to the methodology right
in other words you know if japan is very
active
in public diplomacy efforts in a country
is your treatment effect
going to be attenuated because citizens
are already being
aggressively primed with the same kind
of information and
does the degree of public diplomacy
differ
between korea and malaysia for example
the assumption
seems to be it's going to be the same
there is no effect
but is is that really true um i mean the
other possibility is that
through these existing efforts citizens
would become more susceptible to prime
somehow so that that might be another
possibility
but in either case i think some
discussion of that would be useful
um and the second point was you know
my observation of the public diplomacy
strategy
as as it's occurring seems to be focused
lately
on opinion leaders and uh i've even
heard influencers used
by some officials and and sort of
thinking about that
mechanism right so if these messages are
coming from
people you trust within your own country
does that make a difference versus if
it's obviously coming
from the the source country because that
that seems to be
at least from my sort of very
qualitative
impressionistic sense where a lot of the
attention is going
in the public diplomacy sphere these
days is let's focus on these people who
have a lot of twitter followers and try
to change their mind
um so for future research that might be
worth thinking about
thanks
great thank you uh michael ortiz is next
ah thanks um yeah thank you for the
presentation um going this late uh some
of the points i wanted to make have
already been made
uh particularly by jennifer and ben um
so let me let me try to uh
summarize what i see as sort of the
source of some of these uh
concerns and that is that
while you you run the experiment in the
way you should and you check for balance
within your cases
in all the right ways and you have
presumably enough power to
to make the inferences you want to make
within the cases
for the kind of big points that you're
making in the paper what you really have
is an n of two
right you've got south korea malaysia
and i guess to
senders as well and a lot of the
questions i think
come from the notion that you
acknowledge in the paper
that there are a lot of differences
between these countries
um that may be confounding
at least your interpretations of the
results
that you're that you're finding so
one thing that struck me on the aid
treatment in particular is that i just i
just looked and at least according to
the imf south korea now has a higher per
capita income than japan
uh and much much higher than china of
course so aid
who knows how aid plays and particularly
japanese aid plays
in the korean sort of imagination is it
is it
envy is it jealousy is it resentment
what's what's going on
um there's a lot there's a lot there and
then you know south korea's
smack in the middle of japan and china
it's affected by how
hard power in lots of ways um
it's it's different from malaysia in so
many ways that it's hard to isolate
um the thing that's really causing the
difference is it
is it this politicization of the
bilateral relationship or is it
something else
um on the politicization i will echo the
the points made earlier
that that um i think it would be useful
for you at the very least in the
conclusion
uh to suggest more systematic ways
to measure politicization
so i think you started with these two
cases where you korea and malaysia where
you just figured
this is going to be uncontroversial
everyone's going to agree that
that the relationships between korea and
the two
uh the two senders are clearly
politicized
and for malaysia there seem to be any
evidence of that
um it'd be nice it's always professor
and i use the word churlish it's always
difficult to
to comment on an experiment to say well
here's all the things you should have
done
um but to have sort of off-diagonal
cases
right where one of them had a
politicized relationship with china but
not with japan and the other vice versa
if there are any any
such cases to get a little bit of
leverage on that
i also wanted to echo what jennifer said
about about the treatment of culture
in korea to my understanding
culture gets sort of um uh
hijacked in the politics of the
relationship between the two countries
there's no particular cultural disputes
specifically but but because culture and
uh and um industry
uh money are so related the south korean
government likes to use culture as sort
of a weapon
um in its politicize political disputes
with japan
so is it distinction is the is the
fraught nature of their relationship the
politicization inflation really about
culture
or is cultures is being used there and
so then you're gonna is it really a good
case for finding the
impact of the cultural treatments uh
that you're looking for
um again to echo professor nice claim
our
point about time series you do mention
covet is
as a potential issue for doing this in
february of 21
but just any snapshot uh is
is going to be a bit of an issue because
diplomacy is a continuous thing it you
know
it waxes and wanes south korea and japan
for example or or with china you know
the relationship
warms and it cools and it warms in the
cools and so if the questions happen to
be asked if people at a time when
when the south korean government is
explicitly or implicitly
uh you know organizing a boycott of
japanese cultural products you're gonna
get a very different set of answers
probably from your respondents than if
it's in a in a warmer period
or whatever um
the the last thing i wanted to say is
and here
jennifer really did kind of anticipate
um one of my suggestions which is for
those of us who are not already steeped
in the literature
on soft power a slightly more
rigorous summary of of
that literature about why it matters and
and about how it works uh
i think would be useful for for
especially if you want to send this to
sort of a general
interest journal and how it works what i
mean by that
is your measure is looking at these
surveys
um and i guess this could be said about
the other paper that we'll discuss next
too
are looking at sort of the impact on
public opinion
right just the average citizen in the
street and how to what are their
feelings about this country in terms of
trust or
things like that how does that translate
to
the the goals that the sending country
is actually seeking to fulfill so how
does how does how does a warm feeling
about japan or about china
um you know make its way up to your own
government's
relationship with this ending country
i'm sure this is in the literature
already
in general terms but if you could um
if you could summarize that for the
reader but then also think about how you
might
get at that in terms of in terms of your
your examination
so this may be more of an observational
accompaniment to the experiment
but just uh as a comparativist who
doesn't study
international relations of power the so
what question
really was you know flashing over my
head as i was reading
it's like this is all kind of very
interesting internally within the
experiment but
especially when you were looking for um
sort of the longevity of these things
and you said you did a follow-up
a week later or something like that a
couple weeks later and i think in
in in the other paper it was they showed
results that lasted three weeks or
something like that
what's three weeks in in a diplomatic
relationship
um you know how big a deal is this
some sense of that so i'm not
necessarily saying it's not a big deal
but sell it to the reader
great thank you and then uh finally us
tsujong lim
and maybe uh can we also okay
thank you for um sharing a fascinating
research with us
i actually shared them many a point so
many uh strong
points about the paper but i also share
um
some of the concerns about the
treatments whether the treatments
are actually manipulating the things
that the helpers wanted to
to manipulate and on that point
um if you were to do a follow-up survey
or redesign the survey one thing i
just wanted to suggest as also one of
the south korean audience in the room
was to make the treatment sharper and in
doing so also try to make it more
more relational more directed um
and and sort of um
centering on on the empathy so in these
treatments across all three
issue areas the treatments for videos it
doesn't have any particular
target it doesn't at least mention the
target but i think what south koreans
um especially appreciate when it comes
to the relationship with japan
especially the ordinary public in south
korea is how
some of the japanese some of the
japanese politicians are actually
thinking similarly with koreans so maybe
if there's some of the treatments maybe
not in terms of the video which is
which is harder but in just traditional
vignettes if
somehow for instance the political value
treatment mentions
how as democracy we japan
are quite similar to korea in having
this
vibrant civil society uh in in in this
way you can make the public diplomacy
activity relational and and uh resort to
to uh sort of empathy i think this might
be the key actually in in how the public
diplomacy should be conducted in a in a
more politicized
and a rivalry sort of setting because in
that way you can
kind of see how japan is also reaching
out to
us koreans not just to the broader
audience across the globe
so i think um i i just wonder if this
sort of more relational message
more directed message have a different
impact especially if the the
impact the module impact could be
greater when under the conditions of
politicization
about the the um measuring of the
dependent variable i was wondering if
you can
take advantage of the competition
environment here between japan and korea
and whether you actually had a post
choice type of tv whether you will
you will um cooperate more with china
or japan sort of thing instead of just
um
asking them one by one and say if
um this competition even though there is
a slight backlash
maybe still then the the the recipient
of the public diplomacy would choose
us over the the competitor so i just
wanted to see
how this competition dynamic might be
incorporated
into the survey design especially in the
in the east asian context
that's it for me great
thank you and last tahoe kim thank you
i really enjoyed good comments
and uh just to try to add two small
points
one about the case selection and second
one
uh policy recommendation
i think a
the motivation to start this paper
comes from japan china regional rivalry
hard power rivalry between one
us ally and one competitor
of u.s and then you became curious
how these two countries soft power works
for korea which means
you picked up case out of strong hard
power
and then try to relate soft power to
explain your hard power relationship
but yellow reality south korea is a more
strong soft power center to china and
japan
in kpops and sports and cultures
and china controls korean soft power
and japan just leave it to play in
domestic politics
so i think you should think about the
influence of soft power of south korea
to these great powers
if you try to academically compare
the role of soft and hard power my
second point is about the solution
that this paper is very strong in the
deductive logic
the key is a politicization
in domestic politics but the problem is
south korea's domestic politicization
on history issue here the key is
who captured the power in south korean
politics
if you look at the past 20 years history
whenever controversial a conservative
righty political camp captures korean
power
a korea-japan relations get ease
and much more cooperative and security
issues
but like this time liberal and lefty
government captures power
all problems becomes politicized
so this paper implies korean domestic
politics
which cannot be controlled by japan and
china will decide
the impact of hard power and software
relationship
between japan and korea between
korea and china and korea and japan
thank you very much
great well thanks thank you to all of
the panel participants and especially to
our discussions professor joe and i
professor
maria nikova professor aticitago and
professor sister of kobayashi
for those fantastic comments i i'm again
going to resist the urge to give a
lengthy response
to these great great suggestions
um and uh you know points
to push our thinking further along so i
think that it you know whether
it's thinking carefully about what the
treatments are manipulating what
somebody's giving us or something we can
clarify
to these bigger questions about the
theory that the paper is trying to
develop i mean i think
as you know professor and i and and a
bunch of people suggested you know
thinking
thinking over time and how this changes
and how as as
a uh professor catalinx suggested how
governments are actually doing this can
help to answer this question
that mike thomas asked about you know
what what's theoretically
interesting what's theoretically
interesting here um so this has given us
great food for thoughts i really
appreciate it
i'm mindful however that everyone was
promised a zoom break
um and so i do want to to stick to that
while still giving
uh the next paper presenters ample time
to discuss they're really excellent
exciting
uh paper so uh as planned let's try to
come back
at uh at 8 40. so it gives a slightly
shorter break than planned but still
maybe a little time to walk around
and get away from our screen so thanks
thanks again so much and i'll
see everybody in about eight minutes
thank you